Oh et welcome to my home this is how the
other half lives a house in the middle
of Manhattan five bedrooms five and a
half bathrooms oh and there's a hidden
elevator so you don't lose your breath
going up the five flights of stairs
everyone likes to see the elevator
I'm gonna call it as a Real Housewife of
New York City Sonja Morgan is known for
being the life of the party
if being Sonja is so wrong why does it
feel so right but she isn't just a lady
who lunches this is like our
entertainment room our you know it's on
the first floor of the house so I do a
lot of parties here this gets the most
action I can't board meetings here I can
have fashion meetings I can have friends
over
cocktail parties and on the same level
another rare real estate sighting
outdoor space in New York City I just
came back from France and sprinklers are
out so I had to go to Home Depot to buy
all-new flowers famous for her gaggle of
interns Sonja has clearly let them have
a summer off what are these interns to
the list could go on and on I run a
five-floor home to start okay
on to the second floor a classic dining
room leading into a kitchen that has
seen its fair share of action on the
show you know LuAnn has been to a lot of
parties here this is where she told me
that she was dating my on the side guy
my in-between guy and I'm loving him
ain't we gonna get married
good time my tom LuAnn de Lesseps is now
engaged to Tom and things haven't been
the same between the two women he was
kind of minimizing what we had together
which I didn't appreciate cuz I think
men should always put a woman on a
pedestal
that's the hurdle we need to get over
here folks moving on up to the third
floor where the entire floor serves as
the master suite it's hard it's really
hard on the fourth floor Sonja's
daughter Quincey reign supreme when
she's not at boarding school we are
packing to go back to the dorm at my
daughter's school tomorrow
and with two bedrooms the fifth floor is
a guest dream come true which LuAnn
knows a thing or two about I just came
to ask you I'd go to hotels I thought
it'd be more fun to sail the game oh yes
of course so will we be seeing Sonja and
her magnificent home for another season
you know I'm not even dealing with it
right now